Nó ngày 3,5 năm, thông tin từ công an tính đồng này đơn vị đạo
hỏng tất kêu lợt đuổi trà vụ sức hải 3 người trong một gia đình tại sả đất nhau.
Thưa đó, bí canh lên xí tụng đã thực hiện hình vì phản tội một mình không có đủ
phạm trong quả trình về an. Cơ quan cạnh rất đuổi trà khởi tổ bí canh đời với tụng
về cất tổ, dính lời cứ tài sản, về hỏi tài sản và tăng chữ, vẫn chuyển
sự dụng và một bản chế phép vụ khi quân dụng. Ngoài ra, cơ quan đuổi trà
tình tên nhìn, với văn vật chú phường của này, tình đồng này và phạm qua hủy chú phường chung thành tình thánh
Ngoài ra, cơ lợt đuổi trà trở thấy tụng không có công an việc làm, không có tuy nhập như lại hưởng
tụi lỗi sống xa hoa, tưởng đăng lên phê sống cá nhân thị hiện việc đi giù lịch, mô sám xem
một tổ và khối lớn để đi phượt. Mô xuống và tưởng đi xanh bánh, thăm ra hội xuống xanh, thăm ra
các trở trời cảm giác mạnh và các lại đi bảo lực. Tụng từ la sinh viên trường đại học công nghệ thông tin,
nhưng đã bỏ học giữa trường và tưởng năm hợp lúc mấy một tùng phạm tội chung các tệ sản bị xử ăn 2,5 tưởng tổ chèo.
Với bản tình 3 hưởng tụng lưới là động và đi có tình thư sai, tụng đánh này sình ý định thực hiện thành viết người, cứ tệ sản.
Lăng người tưởng dự giữ sống xanh và tưởng suyên xanh bánh, nên tổng sáo định bản thân sẽ sử dụng xuống để thực hiện về ăn.
Để thực hiện em yêu, tụng bản xem một tổ lấy tiền đặt mô xuống quân dụng cùng 18 năm viên đạn và các khu khỉc.
Bỏ hộ đi cạnh, mô mấy cấp sách đèn viên, hành chuồng đầu, tóc giả, lưới câu, dây dù, các bạn của nảo, dây dễ bể thi đổi hiện giả,
nhằm chân sự phát hiện và đánh lạc rung truy sẽ của các quan chiếc năng sau khi về ăn tổ phát.
Theo cái quả điều tra, kếm lại của tùng là tình ra định nạn nhân dầu có ở bị lập nơi hệ hệ lãnh để về ăn,
sau khi đã trình bị đe đủ các công cụ, phương tệ nơi trên, tùng đi khảo sát tình trọn con mùi và đi điều về ăn.
Đồ thằng tạm là nhiều cuộc sọng ăn lắm, tùng phát hiện cụ sợ tùng mua nông sản khi hạnh tại sả đất nhau có nhà cụ khăn sàng,
trong nhà có nhiều tệ sản và ở một mình nơi hệ lãnh, nên tùng đã nhiều lần đến khảo sát,
năm so sấu người xí sống, cứ lực xí hoạt của gia đình. Đặc biển đứa bàn, sau định hùng tình công kế ăn và tổ thác,
sau khi nghiên cứu xác định gió một kêu phương ăn thì tình cứ định ra tay về ăn.
Ngay mùa tắng nguyên năng ăn nhiều cuộc sọng ăn lắm, tùng xuất phát đường nơi ở tệ phương phương lắm,
bình phức khú, một mình điều khiển sẽ mấy đi đến bệnh vệnh thành tâm phương lắm mình, tình đông này và người xe tại đây.
Rồi đón xe khách đi đa lạch, tự nơi lực tức đón xe quay về gá tương dầu dây thí xuống,
đón xe khách đi đến hát tư à mà ta, đón xe ông đi tới trước cũng suy tiến, đón xe biết đi bệnh xem đến đông.
Lúc bệnh dừng em 2 tháng 12 năm như khu chăm hâm i lắm, tùng lên xe khách thành công đi đến xả bông bóng,
tùng giữ tục đón xe ông đi sả đất nhau. Cách nhà nạn nhân khoảng 2 kêu mát, tùng xuất xe,
đi bộ trở lâu cao xù tư tư cận cơ xe tụng mô đong sản thi này.
Mô lần thay đổi phương tệ trên đường dưới chuyện thịt tụng đều thay đổi cho phục trinh với với lứt đổi tóc giả,
mùa cết lưới trái, đào khổ chàng chúng ký mặt, trước khi tiếp cận mục tiêu quay ăn,
tùng thay toàn bộ cho phục đăng mặc, tức tục mặc bộ đồng phục truy rủ trẻ xem một tồ phượt.
Đào kính vọng hộ, mũ bảo hộ, lăng thay, lắp xung bắn từ chính sác, rồi xử dụng móc cộ móc và cũng các cuộc phần.
Bộ xe dù cơ xài để dịch khúc định giữ vỏ nhảnh nhân khi phát hiện ra định nạn nhân tập trung an tối thịt tùng đứng tự biệt lâu cao xù đối dịch.
Cách kỷ chi cơ nạn nhân 3 mấy, sả đặt lên tục làm chết bà người, mắn nổ mắt cao mera rồi và phòng các kết sát lấy tài sản của ra định nạn nhân và tổ phát.
Chỉ trong 5 sáo dự kể từ khi tiếp nhận thông tin buạn,
lúc 18 mấy phút mềm năng tháng 18, khu chăm ha mi lắm.
Cơ quan kể rất đều tra công an tình đồng này đã bắt sự lây sĩ tùng và tuy sữa tổn mộ tăng bật.
Cái sản lý quan vụ an, bởi kích tâm hình chương đều tra, làm só, chỉ bắt chỉ để đối tự liên quan để sử li như biệt.
Trong thời hạn ha mi ngay, cơ quan kể rất đều tra đã bắt sự thêm bà đối tự 1 bản tục khi tùng đã sự giữ kể an và kết lượng đều tra,
đế nghĩ chỉ tổ các vị càng theo phuy định.
Cơ quan đều tra, vình kìm sát in zinh và tỏa ninh dừng tình đồng này đã học.
Thống nước sẽ đưa vụ an ra sẽ sử cố khai trong thống mềm 1 năm 2018 để kì thời gian an dưới lận và lập lại tình gình an in chực tự tại đi phương.